Hello, welcome to How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收听《老爸老妈的浪漫史幕后故事》。
This is our bonus episode, which we lovingly and faithfully refer to as general questions, general questions.
这是我们的特别番外篇，我们充满爱意且忠实地称它为“常规问题、常规问题”。
That was pretty good.
那个挺不错的。
That was actually pretty good.
那个其实真的挺不错。
We're trying to sync this up and it was one of our more successful efforts.
我们正努力把它俩合拍上，这是我们比较成功的一次尝试。
This is a these are questions about episode seven, the matchmaker and the cockamouse, which if If that is a detail that orients you more into the story than the more enduring story from that episode.
这是一个……这些是关于第七集《红娘》和“蟑螂鼠”的问题，如果这个细节比那一集里更长久的故事更能让你联想到剧情的话。
So we're talking about the matchmaker, we're talking about the cockamouse and we'll hand it over to our beloved producer and friend, Alec Lev, who will fire these questions our way.
所以我们聊的是《红娘》，聊的是“蟑螂鼠”，我们要把它交给我们的挚爱制作人兼朋友阿莱克·莱夫，由他来向我们抛出这些问题。
Thank you very much.
非常感谢。
I want to start out with a question that I'm piecing together something from dozens of not hundreds of questions.
我想从一个问题开始，我把成百上千个问题中的一些内容拼凑在了一起。
I think people just like to hear about life on set, like literally on the set.
我想人们只是喜欢听听片场的生活，字面意思上的片场生活。
They'd love to hear about you know when people when people break and you make people laugh But just anything about where where do you keep your script and and are you eating in the middle of it?
他们很想听听，你知道的，当大家笑场的时候，你们是怎么让大家笑的，或者任何关于你们把剧本藏在哪里的事，以及你们在拍戏间隙会吃东西吗？
Just those little little fun facts that I think people would enjoy hearing Josh.
就这些我觉得大家会乐于听到的小趣事，乔什。
Yeah, well key note address about You know what's it what's life like on a sitcom set?
好的，那么关于“情景喜剧片场的生活是什么样的”的主题演讲来咯？
I mean we're on stage 22 at the Fox lot in West LA.
我的意思是，我们在西洛杉矶福克斯片场的22号摄影棚。
It's it's a huge like aircraft hangar basically Um, if you look up, there's just, it looks like endless wood and beams and cross, you know, things in the sky and there's lights hanging from and yeah, hugely high ceiling.
它基本上就像一个巨大的飞机机库。
Um, probably, uh, yeah, not great for your allergies.
如果你抬头看，到处都是无尽的木头、横梁，你知道的，天花板上有各种交叉的东西，灯就挂在上面，而且天花板真的超级高。
Um, but, um, there's like dust from Planet of the Apes and flying around in there.
可能，呃，对你的过敏症不太友好。
I think Planet of the Apes was out there.
但是，呃，里面到处都是《人猿星球》留下的灰尘在飞舞。
Yeah.
我觉得《人猿星球》就是在那里拍的。
Some really classic old Hollywood movies were shot on that stage.
是的。
It was really fun.
一些非常经典的老好莱坞电影就是在那个摄影棚里拍的。
Also, when you're on the Fox, if you drive in the front gate, you see the huge painted Simpsons mural.
真的很酷。
There's, isn't Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker, there was a thing on there.
还有，如果你从福克斯的前门开车进去，你会看到巨大的辛普森一家手绘壁画。
So you drive on to these lots and you feel like you're in old Hollywood kind of immediately.
还有，那上面不是还有达斯·维达和卢克·天行者吗，以前有个那样的东西。
It's really- And in the shadow of the die-hard building, also.
所以当你开车进入这些片场时，你会立刻觉得自己身处老好莱坞。
That's right.
真的……而且也笼罩在《虎胆龙威》大楼的阴影之下。
We looked up and saw the die-hard building for nine seasons.
没错。
You know, there's a, there's a candy cart floating around that has like, like any candy you could ever imagine, but it also had a, uh, uh, uh, weren't there piles of scripts that if you needed a script, like the latest revision of the script?
我们抬头就能看到《虎胆龙威》大楼，看了整整九季。
So I think like when you're on a show, especially if you're on camera, you have to train yourself, you cannot eat all the candy you want because you will look different by the end of the season than you did when you started.
你知道的，那里有个到处移动的糖果车，上面有你能想象到的任何糖果，但它也有一个，呃，呃，呃，难道不是有一堆剧本吗？如果你需要剧本的话，比如最新修订版的剧本？
It's really true.
所以我觉得当你在出演一部剧时，特别是如果你要在镜头前出镜，你必须克制自己，你不能随心所欲地吃所有糖果，因为到这一季结束时，你的外表会和刚开始时不一样。
I remember I would, I never liked carrying the whole script.
这绝对是真的。
I would rip out the three pages, four pages of the scene.
我记得我以前，从来不喜欢把整本剧本随身携带。
And I would rehearse them most of the time.
我会撕下那场戏的三四页。
I was somewhat off book, sometimes I wasn't, but I would, sometimes if it was just a little, I would just isolate what my lines and I would have them.
然后我会练习它们，大多数时候我差不多能脱稿，有时不能，但有时如果只是一小部分，我就会把我的台词单独拿出来，然后带着它们。
And then I would either, I'd put them under a prop on the desk, you know, like on a desk or a lot of pages underneath.
然后我会把它们塞在桌子上的某个道具下面，你知道的，比如放在桌上或者一堆纸下面。
I'm sure that a props and set dressing were just finding pages stuffed in couch cushions and behind pillows constantly.
我敢确定，道具组和布景师肯定经常在沙发垫子里和抱枕后面翻出塞进去的剧本页。
Because you forget that you left them there, right?
因为你会忘记自己把它们落在那儿了，对吧？
I would have them in my back pocket.
我会把它们塞进后裤兜里。
Sometimes wardrobe would have to come through and say, oh, your script's poking out, your back pocket.
有时服装组不得不走过来提醒说：“哦，你的剧本露出来啦，在后裤兜里。”
But the other thing that we would do, especially if there was a scene with all five of us, and what's weird is the more successful the show gets, the lazier the actors get.
但我们做的另一件事，特别是如果有我们全部五个人的群戏时——诡异的是，剧越成功，演员就越懒。
because you get better at doing it, you get better at, you get better at doing it, you get better at, you know your character, I mean, it's so hand in glove, you're just, you know how to play this character, you own the character, they know you own it.
因为你越来越擅长演戏了，你越来越擅长……你越来越擅长表演，你知道你的角色，我的意思是，这简直是不谋而合，你就是，你知道如何扮演这个角色，你对角色驾轻就熟，他们也知道你吃透了这个角色。
So we had this wonderful script supervisor named Janet Kagan, who was British and sassy and hilarious.
所以我们有一位非常棒的剧本总监叫珍妮特·卡根，她是英国人，性格泼辣又搞笑。
And she was always right next to Pam behind the monitor.
她总是坐在监视器后面的帕姆旁边。
And she marks up like where people got lime I'm strong or right or circles takes that Pam says, that's a good take and she'll circle it.
她会标记出大家的台词哪里说得很有力量或很准确，或者把帕姆说“这条不错”的镜头圈起来。
And it's a whole like code.
那是一套完整的密码。
She's got colored pencils and all sorts of stuff that I never understood.
她有彩色铅笔和各种我从没搞懂的东西。
But we would often gather around and Janet would run lines with us.
但我们经常聚在一起，让珍妮特陪我们对台词。
And we would do that right before we shot.
我们会在开拍前就这样做。
We would just gather around Janet's podium and learn the lines, you know, not always.
我们就会聚在珍妮特的立式台子周围背台词，你知道的，也不是每次都这样。
Sometimes we would come in and we'd really have them.
有时我们走进片场时就已经把台词背得滚瓜烂熟了。
But a lot of times you were learning as you went.
但很多时候你都是在边做边学。
And then the moment she was funny to witness because it would be like, you're acting and you're trying to get out of your workings and seeing it, working through the lines a little bit and Janet would be like eating a bowl of her puffins.
而且当时看她觉得挺逗的，因为你会看到她一边在演戏，一边努力跳脱出自己的表演状态去揣摩，稍微琢磨一下台词，而珍妮特（Janet）就在那一边吃着一碗她的帕芬脆。
And just be like, what's the mean by breaking up?
然后就来一句：“分手的点在哪里啊？”
And then just go back to it.
接着又马上投入到状态中。
You should be doing that.
你真该学学她那样。
It was also great to hear Janet, this British woman like reading Barney lines, like reading like the kind of gnarliest Barney lines in this thick British accent.
而且听到珍妮特这个英国女人念巴尼的台词也很有意思，就像是用那种浓重的英国腔念着巴尼最离谱的台词。
It was really funny.
真的太搞笑了。
So yeah, I mean, it was always kind of, you know, I'd walk in and if we were there in the morning you kind of blaze through craft service and maybe grab some oatmeal and a cup of coffee.
所以，对啊，我的意思是，感觉一直都是这样，你知道的，我走进去，如果早上我们就在那儿，你就会顺路去后勤餐饮区（craft service）匆忙拿点燕麦片和一杯咖啡。
And you ask him craft service like what's for lunch?
然后你问后勤的人：“午饭吃什么？”
You know, it's just rice.
你知道的，就是米饭。
Breakfast rice.
早餐饭。
We did often freak out about how much we love breakfast.
我们确实经常为我们有多爱早餐而大惊小怪。
Breakfast rice was good.
早餐饭挺不错的。
I think that was in the later seasons.
我想那是在后面的几季里。
Yeah, it was.
对，确实是。
Yeah.
对。
But you know, it becomes your home away from home.
但你知道的，那成了你的第二个家。
You know, you have your meals there.
你知道的，你在那儿吃饭。
You get to know the crew.
你开始认识剧组的工作人员。
You get to know the crews, spouses and kids.
你开始认识工作人员的配偶和孩子。
And I don't know, I think that people, when they watch how I met your mother, I think I've said this before, they think it's five people, but it's 75 people.
而且我不知道，我觉得人们在看《老爸老妈浪漫史》时——我想我以前也说过这个——他们觉得只有五个人，但其实有75个人。
You know, the set is a buzz with people.
你知道的，片场到处都是人，非常热闹。
And when in between scenes, people are coming along and they're fussing with your face and they're fussing with your hair and they're giving you a note and they're fussing with your collar.
在两场戏的间隙，大家会围过来，给你整理脸上的妆容，给你弄弄头发，给你提点意见，顺便帮你整理一下衣领。
You know, there's just a very active life going on on set.
你知道的，片场里正进行着非常生动的生活。
Yeah.
对。
And it really matters what that energy is of that life, what that kind of ecosystem is.
而这种生活的能量是什么样的，那种生态系统是什么样的，其实非常重要。
And that's a lot of people bringing that energy.
那是许多人把这种能量带到了片场。
And we just had an amazing, amazing crew that just had the warmest energy where everybody felt safe to do their best work.
我们拥有一个非常、非常棒的剧组，他们有着最温暖的能量，让每个人都觉得在这里可以安心地发挥出最好的水平。
And it was fantastic, doesn't always happen.
这太棒了，这种事并不总是会发生。
A couple of things I could point out.
我有几点可以指出来。
Among the productions from stage 22 on the old 20th Century Fox Lot, Dr. Do Little, 1967.
在老二十世纪福克斯片场第22号摄影棚的作品中，有1967年的《怪医杜立德》。
Oh, cool.
哦，太酷了。
Yeah.
对。
Planet of the Apes 1968 I knew it and nine to five 1980 I forgot about that nine to five so that's a fucking great movie I I did not appreciate that enough at the time that we were like they're shooting dad me Coleman office scenes on there something come on Yeah, come on.
1968年的《人猿星球》，我猜到了，还有1980年的《朝九晚五》，我都忘了还有《朝九晚五》，所以那真是一部他妈的好电影，我当时还没有充分意识到这一点，我们就好像是在那儿拍老爸科尔曼的办公室场景什么的，拜托，得了吧，对，得了吧。
Yeah, that's fantastic So meals I know as I was only there in the later season to sort of put together what we were talking about in the main episode of this episode talking about this episode of the technology sure and Josh your comfort level.
对，太棒了。所以关于吃饭，我知道——因为我只在后几季才加入，来整理一下我们在本集的主节目里讨论的内容，关于本集的科技，当然还有Josh你当时的舒适度。
I just remember closing in the seasons eight and nine, the delta, the time between cut and the cell phone coming out to make a call to Scott shorter and shorter and shorter.
我只记得在第八季和第九季的尾声，导演喊“卡”之后，到拿出手机给斯科特打电话之间的时间间隔，变得越来越短，越来越短，越来越短。
Where was that cell phone?
那手机是从哪儿拿出来的？
How would you already have it in your hand?
你怎么会已经把它拿在手上了？
Pam is very, very, Pam is the loveliest director of the loveliest human.
帕姆（Pam）是个非常、非常优秀的导演，也是个极好的人。
She's the kindest person she never got mad at anybody once.
她是那种最善良的人，一次也没有对任何人发过火。
I never saw her as her voice, but she would have been knowing and have these little passive aggressive things she would say.
我从来没见她大声说过话，但她会心领神会，并说出一些带有这种微小被动攻击性的话。
And she was always in the right, of course.
当然，而且她总是对的。
I don't mean in a bad way.
我不是在贬义上说这个。
But I remember she would, if she would see you guys or any of the actor, any of the cast, go right to their phone and then be on the phone the whole time.
但我记得，如果她看到你们或者任何演员、任何卡司，直接拿起手机然后一直在玩手机。
And we're coming up on her calling action again.
而我们马上又要听到她喊“开始”了。
She would, while she would look over and she would just say, an actor prepares.
她就会一边看过来，然后冷不丁地说一句：“一个演员的自我修养。”
You know, I did, it was devastating.
你知道的，我当时觉得这简直是毁灭性的打击。
It's all she had to say through words and actor prepares.
她只需要说这几个字：“一个演员的自我修养”。
I did a show for NBC for a season called Rise, which was a really lovely show that Jason And I gave myself a challenge that I stuck to the entire time, which was I never brought my phone to set.
我曾在NBC拍过一季名为《非凡up》的剧，那是一部非常温馨的剧，由杰森……我给自己设定了一个挑战，并且从头到尾都坚持了下来，那就是我从来不把手机带到片场。
I would have it in my dressing room, I would check it when I had to go do a costume change or whatever.
我会把它放在化妆间里，等我去换戏服或者干嘛的时候看一眼。
I never once brought it set, but it was also when I was learning guitar.
我从来没把它带到片场过，但那也是我刚开始学吉他的时候。
So I brought my guitar to set and we were often filming in this theater, this big auditorium that they actually built on a stage in Green Point in Brooklyn.
所以我把吉他带到了片场，我们当时经常在一个剧院拍戏，那是他们实际上在布鲁克林绿点的一个舞台上搭建的大礼堂。
And I would sit in the audience and I would, you know, learn my lines, but I would noodle around on the guitar.
我就会坐在观众席里，你知道的，背台词，但同时也会拨弄几下吉他。
I was learning how to finger pick and I'm pretty convinced giving myself those hours to play the guitar while not being on my own set.
我当时在学指弹，而且我深信不疑，把那些时间用来弹吉他，而不是待在自己的片场里。
It made me such a better guitar player and I think it made me a better actor, a more present actor on set.
这让我成了一个更好的吉他手，而且我认为这也让我成为了一个更好的演员，一个在片场更加专注的演员。
So I tried to do that.
所以我尽量这么做。
The phone is a focus killer.
手机绝对是注意力的杀手。
It's actually prohibits you from getting to know your cast members as well as you could.
它实际上会妨碍你尽可能好地去了解你的演员同伴。
I agree.
我同意。
It's not good.
这可不好。
We are all very seduced.
我们都被深深地诱惑了。
As we talked about earlier today, those phones came out as we were all sort of coming to age there and it's true.
正如我们今天早些时候讨论的那样，当我们差不多都在那个时期风华正茂的时候，智能手机就出现了，确实如此。
But that was Pam's little trick to get people back.
但这正是帕姆把大家重新聚在一起的小把戏。
That's wonderful that you made that choice.
你能做出那样的决定真是太棒了。
I hope every actor decides to make that choice.
我希望每个演员都决定做出那样的决定。
And by the way, I say this is a proper phonetic.
顺便说一句，我说这话是以一个正经演员的身份。
I'm not like a...
我不是在……
No.
不。
Because that's why it's even more meaningful.
因为正因如此，它才更有意义。
Because everyone, yeah.
因为每个人，对。
Yeah.
对。
And you were by no means any sort of worst defender on this set.
而且你绝对算不上是这个剧组里表现最差的那类人。
on the set.
在片场。
I hope it's not coming across now.
我希望现在听起来不会让人觉得我在装。
No, no, no, no, no, no.
不，不，不，不，不，不。
Time would bust that line out on any actor.
泰姆随时都会对任何演员说出那句台词。
Of course, you appreciate everyone who's currently on their phone right now.
当然，你肯定会感谢现在正拿着手机的所有人。
Yeah, no, listen to the podcast is fine.
对，不，听播客没问题。
So in the in the proper episode, we also shouted out our the not hour, but the growing him and fans group.
所以在正片里，我们也大声感谢了我们的——不是我们的，而是粉丝创建的那个《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝群。
And I just want to a I posted there.
我只想在里面发个帖。
I said, hey, I don't want to ask any questions here.
我说，嘿，我不想在这里问什么问题。
Brittany just had a funny one.
布兰妮刚刚提出了一个有趣的问题。
She says not a question but more of a comment.
她说这不是一个问题，更像是一个评论。
I was going to start the series again and watch it week by week along with the pod.
我本来打算重新开始看这部剧，然后每周跟着播客的进度一集一集重温。
I'm now on season seven episode five.
我现在看到第七季第五集了。
It's just going to have three of these potato chips and I'll put them back away.
我只要吃这三片薯片，然后就把它们收起来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the hyper-fixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，“超级修复”播客的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会倾听听众的烦恼并试着为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York, or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
比如这样的烦恼：我30岁了，却不敢在纽约开车；或者为什么我挂倒挡时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
You have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
你有一个问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的背后隐藏的系统。
That's the hyper-fixed podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的“超级修复”播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论你在哪里收听播客，或者访问hyperfixedpod.com都可以找到它。
And okay, so obviously we did a lot of cockamaws talking in the proper episode, and a little bit of matchmaking, but just to get an origin story there, Devin asks, from the Hemium fans group, so if you join that group, we might ask your questions.
好的，所以显然我们在正片里进行了很多胡扯般的聊天，还有一点点拉郎配，但为了探究它的起源，德文在《老爸老妈浪漫史》粉丝群里问道——所以如果你加入那个群，我们可能会回答你的问题。
Was this episode based on anything anyone's real life at the time, did this matchmaking service actually exist in the area?
这一集是基于当时某人的真实生活吗？这种红娘服务在当地真的存在吗？
If so, did anyone actually try it?
如果是的话，真的有人尝试过吗？
Was it successful?
它成功了吗？
It sounds like, was there such a thing?
听起来像真的吗，真有这种事吗？
I know, it really does.
我知道，真的挺像的。
It's like, yes, it was before electricity, so you had to go to a local matchmaker.
就像是，没错，那是电还没发明之前的年代，所以你得去找当地的红娘。
We walked past a field full of cows, and there she was.
我们走过一片牛群密布的田野，然后她就在那儿。
It feels a little dated, but it's, you know, there were, there were, I think it came from a genre of feel good news story.
感觉有点过时了，但你知道的，确实有，我觉得它源于一种让人感觉温馨的新闻故事类型。
I think that was the original idea because Ted learns about her on Robyn's fluff piece on the news, right?
我想这才是最初的想法，因为泰德是通过罗宾在新闻里做的那篇轻松愉快的报道了解到她的，对吧？
Robyn's reporter, she does a little feature on this woman who has a 100% success rate matchmaking people.
罗宾是个记者，她做了一个关于这个有着100%配对成功率的女性的小专题报道。
And I think that came from, because there used to be a lot of those stories.
我想这源于，因为过去有很多这样的故事。
It was always like a feel good fluff piece at the end of the news type of thing, like there'd be some, someone who's being like lionized as this person has never failed.
它总是像新闻结尾那种温馨轻松的小品，比如会有某个人被奉为从不失手的传奇人物。
And there was just sort of a genre of fluff piece like that.
那只是一种类似风格的轻松新闻题材。
I think that's where we got it.
我想我们就是从那里得到的灵感。
I don't think it came from a writer's necessarily like real experience.
我觉得它不一定来自编剧们的真实经历。
I don't know how many of the writers were going to match makers, certainly not me.
我不知道有多少编剧会去找红娘，反正肯定不是我。
You know what it does strike me, Craig, that Kobe's job as a local news reporter was such a great way to incite thought in totally.
你知道吗，克雷格，这确实让我觉得，科比作为当地新闻记者的工作，真的是激发完全意想不到的灵感的好方法。
Yeah, you could.
对，你可以的。
That's the launch of this whole episode is a news story Robin does.
整个这一集的开端就是罗宾做的一则新闻报道。
And I love that about it.
我非常喜欢这一点。
And it's happened a couple times now.
而且这已经发生过好几次了。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, it led to a lot of cool stuff.
对，这引发了很多酷炫的事情。
That's how we met her.
我们就是这样认识她的。
And I like actually there's kind of a moment in, I think there's a moment where you kind of in the news story and then kind of go into the scene a little bit.
而且我实际上很喜欢，在新闻报道里似乎有一种转折的时刻，然后顺势切入到场景中一点点。
And it's just it's a great yeah, it was a great catalyst for the episode.
这真的很棒，对，它是这一集非常棒的催化剂。
But I think it began from that from us thinking this would be the type of story Robin would do.
但我认为它始于这种想法，始于我们觉得这就是罗宾会做的那种新闻。
And then we thought they kind of launched this idea.
然后我们觉得它们顺理成章地开启了这个创意。
That's how I remember it anyway.
反正我的记忆是这样的。
Craig, I don't know if you listen, Amy Poehler has a new podcast called, I think it's called Good Hang.
克雷格，我不知道你有没有听过，艾米·波勒有一个新播客叫，我想是叫《美好闲聊》。
I'm probably talking about ours right now on there.
我现在可能正在上面谈论我们呢。
So this is a crossover.
所以这是一次联动。
But she The interviews Tina Fey, her old pal for the first one, and she asks her, like, what delights her?
但她采访了蒂娜·菲，她的老搭档，作为第一期的嘉宾，她问蒂娜·菲，比如什么事能让她感到快乐？
And Tina Fey goes into an extended kind of monologue about, she lives in Jersey, and she's obsessed with her local news reporters, like Saturday, local news is like her happy place.
然后蒂娜·菲长篇大论了一番，说她住在新泽西，而且她对当地的新闻记者着迷得不行，比如周六，当地新闻简直是她的快乐源泉。
And this woman, she liked it, it's a man and a woman, but the woman's name is Pat Battle, which is like an incredible name.
而这个人，她喜欢——那是男女两个主播，但女记者的名字叫帕特·巴特尔，这是一个简直不可思议的名字。
Pat Battle, shout out to Pat Battle.
帕特·巴特尔，向帕特·巴特尔致敬。
And Pat Battle, like she cast her on 30 Rock, like as part of this, like it was like an association honoring like women in media or something and Pat was in the middle.
而帕特·巴特尔——蒂娜·菲曾在《我为喜剧狂》里邀请她客串，作为表彰女性媒体人之类活动的一部分，帕特就站在中间。
Oh, that's so funny.
哦，太搞笑了吧。
And she says I invited her to every premiere and she thinks Pat Battle is a little like, and why do you invite, you gotta stop.
她说我邀请她参加每一个首映礼，而帕特·巴特尔觉得有点……“你为什么总是邀请我，你得停下来了”。
Like you're like obsessed with me.
“感觉你就像对我很着迷一样”。
But she just said there's something about like, Bob's books and Pete's produce.
但她只是说，有些东西就像是“鲍勃书店”和“皮特农场”。
Like she just feels like all is okay with the world even though the local news can be grisly, but there is something so funny about her love of local news, but it's just making me think of Robin.
就好像她觉得世界一切安好，尽管当地新闻有时可能很残酷，但她对当地新闻的热爱实在太搞笑了，这让我不禁想到了罗宾。
I think it's because, and that's why we love Robin.
我想这是因为——这也是我们喜爱罗宾的原因。
That's why we give Robin that job because I think stupid fluff pieces like that about New York City make it feel like a small town.
这就是为什么我们给罗宾安排那份工作，因为我觉得关于纽约市的那些愚蠢又轻松的小花边新闻，能让这座城市感觉像个小镇。
Yes, yes.
没错，没错。
And I think that's what we liked about the what Robin's job brought to it.
我想这就是我们喜欢罗宾的工作所带来的东西。
It's this giant city, but like Robin will find this little human interest story and also shrinking New York down to size to sort of fit within stage 22 in Los Angeles where we're shooting, there's something about it.
这是一个巨大的城市，但罗宾会找到这样一个小小的温情故事，同时把纽约缩小到适合我们在洛杉矶拍摄的22号摄影棚的尺寸，这里面有些很奇妙的东西。
There's something about it as a shrinking effect.
它有一种缩小的奇妙效果。
It's almost like Tina Fey likes it, like it's a kids show.
简直就像蒂娜·菲喜欢的那样，感觉像是个儿童节目。
So there's the local news guy, Pat, our newswoman, Pat Battle.
所以那里的当地新闻男主播叫帕特，我们的女新闻主播叫帕特·巴特尔。
There's something about like, it feels very Mr. Rogers neighborhood or something.
有些感觉就像是《罗杰斯先生的邻居》那类节目。
So that's maybe the appeal of it.
所以这可能就是它的魅力所在。
I also think that there's this idea that New York is just this like crazy metropolis and it's being personal and people are rude.
我也觉得，有一种观点认为纽约只是一座疯狂的大都市，冷漠无情，人们也很粗鲁。
But when you live here, you actually find these little neighborhoods that are like little villages.
但当你住在这里，你其实会发现这些小街区就像一个个小村庄。
You know, you see a lot of the same people all the time, you do get to know your neighbors.
你知道的，你总是能看到很多面孔，你确实会了解你的邻居。
New Yorkers are incredibly friendly.
纽约人真的非常友好。
And I think New Yorkers do appreciate when New York becomes a small town.
而且我认为纽约人确实很感激纽约变得像一个小镇的时候。
Like, snow storms and things that kind of bring us, like have us huddle together.
比如，暴风雪之类的事情把我们聚在一起，让我们挤在一起。
Snow will do it.
雪会有这种效果。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like, lots of things, it's not that hard.
就像，很多事情，其实并不难。
New York can be rendered a small town by some snow one morning.
某个早晨的一场大雪就能让纽约变成一个小镇。
And you would know your local news anchors to play off of Robin Shrabowski and Tina Fey's observation.
为了呼应罗宾·施拉博夫斯基和蒂娜·菲的观察，你肯定知道你们当地的新闻主播。
Like, New York one, that dude Pat Kiernan.
比如纽约一台的那个老兄帕特·基尔南。
Shout out to Pat Kiernan.
向帕特·基尔南致敬。
I think he's still on there.
我想他现在还在那儿播。
And I remember he followed me on Twitter, or something, we followed each other, and I remember interacting with him.
我记得他在推特上关注了我之类的，我们互相关注了，我还记得跟他互动过。
I think he said he liked how much mother at some point.
我想他有一次说他很喜欢《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
And it felt like Brad Pitt saying that.
那种感觉就像布拉德·皮特这么说一样。
I was like, this is fucking Pat Kiernan.
当时我想：这可是他妈的帕特·基尔南啊。
Like, I've been watching him on New York one for 20 years.
我看了他在纽约一台二十年的节目了。
Like, it's like, it's a legitimate, that you can achieve legitimate celebrity status.
这就好比，这是一种合法的，你可以获得真正的名人地位。
Everyone in New York knows what I'm talking about.
纽约的每个人都知道我在说什么。
And other people in New York.
还有纽约的其他一些人。
Like, there were a couple of events I ended up going to in Columbus, like where the local news people that I had been watching since I was a little kid.
比如，我最后去了哥伦布的好几个活动，那些地方有我从小看到大的当地新闻界人士。
And they show up and it is, I mean, it is really like share enters the roof.
他们一出现，我的意思是，真的就像欢呼声掀翻了屋顶。
Like it is like, it is icon time, you know?
就像是，偶像时刻，你知道吗？
It's iconic, totally.
太标志性了，完全是。
Even like the people you would see in subway ads would become local celebrities.
甚至连你在地铁广告上看到的人都会成为当地名人。
Like Dr. Jonathan Zizmore, who would do chemical pee-o on your skin, fucking Dr. Z.
比如乔纳森·齐兹莫尔医生，他会在你皮肤上做化学换肤，他妈的齐兹莫尔医生。
Like the things that make New York a small town are delightful.
让纽约变成一个小镇的那些事情真的非常有趣。
And I think that's what Tina is talking about.
我想这也是蒂娜在谈论的内容。
And I think that's what Robin's job.
我想这也是罗宾的工作。
I know Tina was talking about in Jersey, but it's the same idea.
我知道蒂娜说的是在新泽西，但道理是一样的。
Like there's something about taking a big place and making it small.
把一个巨大的地方变得很小，这其中有种奇妙的感觉。
And Robin's job is so small.
罗宾的工作是那么卑微。
And her detail, she was on shit detail of just looking at the stupidest little story she wanted to be taken seriously.
她负责的都是那些琐碎的差事，只能盯着那些她希望被认真对待的最愚蠢的小新闻。
But I think because she was your way into this, like, smaller version of New York, it was actually very charming.
但我觉得，因为她是带你走进这个更小版本的纽约的引路人，所以实际上非常迷人。
And that's a bit too much of a game in Akron.
这在阿克伦有点太像是个游戏了。
To not be overwhelmed by New York, you have to make it smaller for your.
要想不被纽约压垮，你必须把它缩小到适合你的尺寸。
It has to be small.
它必须是小的。
Yeah.
对。
One phrase that we didn't talk about in the episode proper, that Jordy is, Jordy is trash.
我们在正片里没有讨论过的一个词，就是佐迪，佐迪是个混蛋。
Sorry.
抱歉。
Why do you hate Jordy so much, Alec?
艾利克，你为什么这么讨厌佐迪？
I'm sorry, I don't want to get into it.
抱歉，我不想深入探讨这个。
Jordan just wants us to talk a little bit about tedding out.
乔丹只是想让我们聊聊“泰德化”。
This was, what did you think of this little nugget in the show, tedding out?
节目里的这个小亮点，你觉得怎么样，“泰德化”？
I thought it was tedding Derry.
我以为是“泰德·德里”。
It was tedding Derry, my son's phrase, that I'm heartbroken we didn't use.
是“泰德·德里”，我儿子的口头禅，我因为没用上而心碎。
Yeah, I thought the fact that they loved Ted enough to have him as a verb and like different verb conjugation meaning, I think it felt very warm to me.
对，我觉得他们对泰德喜爱到把他当成一个动词来用，还有不同的动词变位和含义，这让我觉得非常温暖。
It felt like they loved Ted and Ted didn't seem to take it too hard.
感觉他们很爱泰德，而且泰德似乎也没有太放在心上。
And any jokes where this group shares history, I love it, where they know Ted's story verbatim.
任何展现这群人共同经历的笑话我都喜欢，他们对泰德的故事倒背如流。
Yeah.
对。
They do something that I think it's very affectionate and who better to take the piss out of you and give you shit than you're the people who love you the most.
他们做了一件我认为非常充满爱意的事，而且还有谁比那些最爱你的人更适合取笑你、挖苦你呢？
I also think there's something about being in a group of people, maybe friends, maybe just coworkers or whatever.
我也觉得，身处一群人之中，也许是朋友，也许只是同事什么的。
I think we have a tendency to think of ourselves as the normal one, like we're the normal person.
我们往往倾向于把自己当作正常的那个人，就好像我们是正常人。
And everyone.
而所有人。
We're turning the camera like Jim on the office.
我们就像《办公室》里的吉姆一样对着镜头转头。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
And everyone around us is a little eccentric and crazy, but we're like pretty normal.
我们周围的所有人都有点古怪和疯狂，但我们自己挺正常的。
And it's one of those moments where you go, oh, you guys have a verb about me?
这是那种你会突然意识到：“哦，你们竟然专门为我创造了一个动词？”的时刻。
Cause I'm what?
因为我是什么？
I do what?
我都做了什么？
Like, sometimes we need that reflection back.
有时候我们需要这种自我审视。
Like, oh, you're also one of the like crazy cast of characters here.
就像，哦，原来你也是这里这群疯狂角色中的一员。
Yeah, I'm the wacky guy on your sitcom.
对，我就是你们情景喜剧里的那个滑稽怪咖。
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
对，没错，完全正确。
I think that's what that moment said to me, you know.
我觉得那个时刻对我的意义就是这样，你知道的。
Underscore Keenan 99 has a great question and we are trying not to talk about where we're not talking about the future of this episode.
Underscore Keenan 99 有一个很好的问题，我们正努力不谈论——我们不会讨论本剧的未来。
A lot of people, by the way, online have kind of been asked in this question, wait a second, are you guys really not doing any spoilers?
顺便说一句，网上很多人都在问这个问题：“等一下，你们真的完全不剧透吗？”
And I think the answer is we're trying not to people, hopefully are watching the show for the first time.
我的回答是，我们尽量不剧透，希望观众是第一次看这部剧。
Yes, you can go Google all the answers, but you know, don't.
是的，你可以去谷歌搜索所有的答案，但你知道的，别去。
and we're certainly not going to be at fault.
而且我们当然不会承担责任。
But I don't know if you can answer this.
但我不知道你能不能回答这个。
I feel like that's 0.001% of this audience is people are actually good for the first time, so we may be overcorrecting, just to acknowledge that.
我觉得这群观众里只有 0.001% 的人真的是第一次看，所以我们可能矫枉过正了，先承认这一点。
But some people are watching it first time.
但确实有些人是第一次看。
We're trying not to only feel bad.
我们尽量不让人感觉糟糕。
We're running for Elliot, basically.
基本上我们是在为艾略特而跑。
Yes, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
But Keaton says throughout the run of the show, was there a break in case of emergency plan to wrap the show quickly?
但基南说，在整部剧播出期间，有没有准备什么“紧急情况下的备用计划”来迅速收尾？
Had things been pulled by surprise with only one season left?
如果只剩最后一季，事情被突袭砍掉了怎么办？
It was our contingency plan about like, let's wrap it up real quick in season three.
我们有没有什么应急计划，比如在第三季赶紧草草收场？
No, we were too arrogant.
没有，我们当时太傲慢了。
We were like, they're no fucking way.
我们觉得：绝无可能。
We're like, you don't get an ending.
我们就像是：你们休想给我们一个结局。
There's no, you don't want to have that.
没有，你们不会得到那种东西。
It was like, let us, let us find a way to end it.
当时的想法是：让我们自己找个方法结束。
I dare you to cancel us kind of thing.
有种你们就取消我们的那种心态。
So we thank God.
所以感谢上帝。
Thank God people started watching the show and Netflix put it on and the audience grew in the middle because we got to actually get to the end.
感谢上帝，人们开始看这部剧，Netflix上线了它，观众在中途增多了，所以我们才真正得以走到大结局。
All right, well those are our questions here for a vlog strike of what we're talking about but you know the episode We're talking about that Maker Mac maker Mac maker Mac maker.
好了，这些就是我们今天关于博客回顾的问题，我们聊了这些，但你知道我们正在讨论的那集……麦克，麦克，麦克，麦克。
I'm not gonna ask we should be making cocking us.
我不会问，我们本该聊聊做爱。
We're renaming episodes often right here We renamed the pilot this one should be called a cocking us If we're being real about it, then maybe the name of our podcast episode will will honor cocking us rather than yeah I think we can do a little So keep our questions coming on Instagram and on Facebook and even in the comments and YouTube are reading those and online and everywhere you get your comments you can leave them for us.
我们经常在这里重命名剧集，对吧？我们重命名了试播集，这一集应该叫“做爱”。如果我们认真点的话，也许我们的播客单集名字会向“做爱”致敬，而不是……是的，我觉得我们可以做一点微调。所以请继续在Instagram、Facebook甚至评论区和YouTube上给我们提问，我们都会阅读网上的评论，你在哪里留言都可以发给我们。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《老爸老妈浪漫史幕后》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我，艾利克·莱夫制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是蓝点工作室的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗绘制。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分并评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner.
我们的主题曲是《NYC》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和艾略特·康纳斯。
how we made your mother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 how we made your mother.com 即可注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是节目不可或缺的重要部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on substack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com and you can subscribe to my The Dead Father Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）的时事通讯，在 CraigThomasRider.com 阅读克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）已出版的散文，你也可以订阅我的“死者之父社团”（The Dead Father Society），同样在 Substack 上。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的本节目长期活动贡献力量并产生影响，
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures, Marketing provided by by Tank Media.
本期节目的制作得到了 Backyard Ventures 的支持，营销工作由 Tank Media 提供。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
Real question.
真的问题。
It just hit me.
我突然想到了。
Am I in love with you?
我是爱上你了吗？
Or just New York City?
还是只是爱上了纽约市？